last question today hey David can people
be convinced to be gay the same way you
can be peer pressured into drinking or
doing drugs
this question is a disaster it's very
strange to me to include sexual
orientation and drug use in the same
sentence
that is something that actually many
virulent homophobes that we've
interviewed on the program do they
equate they say listen there are all
sorts of undesirable behaviors like
being gay or Druitt doing drugs people
become addicted to gay sex the same way
they become addicted to doing drugs
we've had people on the show who say
those things
they are truly horrible vile depraved
disgusting people so number one I don't
have any idea how you can say that peer
pressure to be gay is like peer pressure
to do drugs that's number one but here's
what I think
look let's pretend that this is a
legitimate question for a second and
kind of play it out you can be convinced
to use drugs and you can be convinced to
participate in a gay Act right like if
we talk about being pressured into doing
things you can't be convinced to be gay
right you're like you you that that
doesn't really exist in the same way
that you can't be pure pressured into
being an alcoholic
you can be peer pressured into drinking
the drinking if it goes on long enough
and you have a genetic predisposition I
guess could lead to you becoming an
alcoholic or something like that
but the language being used here is just
very bizarre so if the question is can
someone be coerced by circumstances into
engaging in an individual act that we
would consider a homosexual act sure I
guess so but if you're asking can
someone be a peer pressured into
becoming gay or a lesbian or bisexual I
think the answer is no it's a very clear
hard no on this one if I'm missing
something or if I misunderstood the
question please let me know but this is
definitely one of the more bizarre ones
that we've received on audience
questions for a while that is it for
today we have a great bonus show for you
next week I'm here Monday Travel day
Tuesday
as I will be broadcasting from mass
torts made perfect a friend of the show
Mike Papantonio conference on Wednesday
Thursday and Friday thanks for joining
us and please become a member get access
to the bonus show at wwlp.com